jeff bezos became the second billionaire
in outer space yesterday
and the one to make it farthest out
irritating
it seems just about every single person
in the country
except for me i think it's terrific
with the way we blow cash in this
country on aimless wars on open borders
dr fauci funding the wuhan laboratory
and freebies from the money printer
jeff bezos has every single right to
spend his wealth on an inspiring joyride
especially before inflation eats all
that money away if texas democrats can
take a mask-less
taxpayer-subsidized private jet booze
cruz to dc
then jeff bezos can slip the surly bonds
of earth
to touch the face of god i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from ivan jc who says
since we're redefining everything i no
longer own a firearm
but rather a cordless hole puncher
that's a great way to put it you know i
think i'm going to have to add that to
the lexicon
in the next edition of speechless two
can play the language games
i'm feeling good i'm glad to be home i'm
feeling virile
i'm feeling energetic and if you want to
feel virile if you don't have this sort
of swarthy skin
if you don't have you know all this
other stuff going on maybe consider
growing a beard
you gotta check out beard supply if
you're going to grow a beard
make sure you do it the right way go to
beardsupply.com because for a limited
time
only you can buy one beard oil product
and get another one for free
beard supply has affordable top quality
products such as beard oils soap beard
shears
and beard balm if you're going to do it
if you're going to go through the hassle
of growing a beard make sure it looks
good make sure it looks strong and manly
go visit our friends at beardsupply.com
today
order yourself two beard oils for the
price of one you can mix and match
different scents or stock up
on an old classic like their best seller
winter number one
whatever you choose make sure you choose
beard supply for a limited time only
make sure you go to beardsupply.com
buy one beard oil and get another one
for
free i love the bezos thing i think it's
great
everyone is going after this guy even
tulsi gabbard
who's quite nice usually and talks about
the spirit of aloha
even she was making the joke that
everyone else was which is
hey bezos please stay up there do the
world a favor by the way i think
that that tweet tulsi sent out i bet
that was a staffer tweet
it's just not the right tone tulsi has a
certain tone
so i would guess that that was probably
a staffer but everyone else was making
the same point
stay up in space no one wants you you're
too powerful you
you control everything by the way
where's my latest amazon package i
ordered it
27 minutes ago where isn't it at my door
yet but yeah we hate you jeff bezos
i think it's it's a great way to spend
money the big complaint
that people are making about jeff bezos
spending some untold
millions of dollars on going up into
space for 15 minutes
is they say jeff you could have solved
poverty
you could have ended poverty but instead
you took a joyride and first of all jeff
bezos can't end poverty
because the poor will always be with you
we know that our very lord and savior
told us that so i think it's probably
true i think we can take that one to the
bank
second of all it's not as though jeff
bezos just blew his money on
some vanity project it's not as though
he just blew his money
on some silly preposterous only
self-indulgent thing
he spent his money on an inspiring
activity he spent his money on an actual
human achievement
to to explore the cosmos to slip the
surly bonds
of earth and to inaugurate an era of
what very possibly will be
commercial civilian space travel that's
great i
i like that among all the mundane
tedious awful things that we're debating
in our politics we can't even agree that
a man
is a man and a woman is a woman we're
talking about letting criminals out of
prison and all sorts of
just ugliness in our politics to see a
guy just shoot himself up into outer
space
with the implicit and i got actually
explicit promise with these multiple
companies richard branson's
jeff bezos that other civilians we will
be able to go
into outer freaking space and look at
this beautiful creation of planet earth
that's wonderful i'm so glad that he
could do that
the criticism of bezos spending his
money this way
reminds me it's almost exactly the same
as the criticism
of the catholic church and i guess some
other churches too it's mostly the
catholic church
for having really beautiful cathedrals
i'm sure you've heard the criticism
before they'll say
the catholic church has all this money
and what they're spending it on huh the
greatest works of art ever that glorify
god
and bring truly sublime and beautiful
art to the common man that when they're
spending it on that instead of some
other like welfare program or something
that's awful that's terrible
they should just cure poverty no you're
never going to cure poverty and
it is a wonderful thing for civilization
when wealthy individuals and wealthy
institutions
spend their money in a way that is
inspiring and uplifting
and gives glory to god and and even in
ways
that promote human achievement i think
that's a wonderful thing i can't believe
i've got to defend jeff bezos
you know that i'm not the biggest fan of
gigantic
multinational corporations and big
technology companies
but credit where credit is due i think
it's great it's way more inspiring
than certain other joyrides that are
going on these days notably
the joyride of texas legislators who
hopped on a private jet they brought a
case of miller light with them and they
they fled the state to dc because they
didn't want to be forced to vote
on a law that they simply didn't have
the votes for
to to impede one of these legislators
is a woman by the name of michelle
beckley
they're they're all fundraising off of
this they've all fled the state they're
not doing their jobs and they're trying
to fundraise on it so this woman i think
is
typical of the group she goes my name is
michelle beckley
i'm one of the brave texas democrats
who came to d.c to fight for voting
rights in my state
now i'm fighting to flip a seat held by
an anti-democracy republican can you
help us get more followers
generally speaking if you need to tell
everyone that you are brave
you are probably not brave if you are
really brave if you're doing something
admirable and virtuous and courageous
people will recognize that
from the act itself you won't need to to
tell them about it
she's obviously not voting fighting for
voter rates she's fighting to
impede voter rights in her state the
people elected their representatives the
representatives are trying to
secure elections and protect our
democracy
by instituting reinstituting very basic
voting rights measures
and the democrats totally are
outnumbered here because the people
don't want their agenda
on this and so they broke the law by
leaving she what is actually happening
here is that this woman
and all of the other people on that
private jet absconded
from the legislature they picked up some
booze
by the way showing of an id along the
way in order to buy alcohol you
generally
need to show an id in this country and
yet they don't believe that you should
show an id to go vote which is why they
fled the state in the first place they
jumped on a private jet
without any masks on i'll also note so
this is now in violation of state law by
fleeing and in violation of federal law
by not wearing the masks on the planes
they go to dc to hang out and fundraise
and then they spread covid to everybody
so they're all coveted rates are spiking
among this group of people they're
calling it
the delta variant airlines that's going
to be the new name of their private jet
so
nothing about this admirable nothing
about this virtuous
nothing about this brave and they're
they're not even
because the covid virus is spreading so
quickly among these legislators
legislators they're not even going to
tell us how many of them have been
infected anymore
so the the num the last number we've got
is that more than 10 of them now have
the virus
we're told that the democrats they're
the party that takes kovid seriously we
awful republicans we're not taking covet
seriously well they're the ones
spreading it on their private jets
cara santucci who's the spokesman for
the
texas house democrats said that they
would be providing daily rapid tests for
the members they've been keeping people
apprised because don't forget they're in
they're in dc right now so they're
meeting with a lot of people on capitol
hill they're meeting with people in the
white house
but it turns out now covet is spreading
like wildfire and so
in a monday statement they're saying
they're no longer even going to release
their daily covid count
and what would you know what would you
know
the white house staffers that they're
meeting with
or all of a sudden coming down with
covid these guys
man they cannot win for losing they say
that they're trying trying to support
democracy they end up
quite clearly subverting democracy they
say they're fighting for the rights of
everyone to vote but they're actually
undermining very basic election
integrity measures that the vast
majority of americans
support and as usual they're saying that
they're taking covet very seriously and
they more than just about anybody
are spreading the virus multiple white
house officials have tested positive for
covid19
including at least one case that the
white house did not publicly disclose
and an aide in nancy pelosi's office who
tested positive right after she met
with the texas democrats
and yet despite to me if if i were
in crisis communications if i were a pr
person
i would look at this situation and let's
say everything were equal
you know the institutions were not
tilted for the democrats
i would look at this and i would say
this is about as bad as this is as bad a
look as it gets
you undermine the will of your
constituents to take a private jet you
break
multiple laws and you spread the
allegedly horrific
worst epidemic in history around the
country
to some of the most powerful people in
the country
this would not be a good look right and
yet because things are not all equal
because the prevailing institutions
entirely favor democrats
the media can't get enough of these
texas
legislators you've really got to protect
yourself these days
it's very important there are lots of
things to protect yourself from not just
the bad guys and the
viruses and the burglars but i'm even
just i'm talking about when your in-laws
come over unannounced all right and
that's why you got to check out
ring with ring you can keep an eye on
your home
from anywhere at any time just from your
phone and by the way i'm not just
talking about the door stop
it's true many people will you know you
you can use the ring alarm you can see
who's ringing your bell you can see and
speak to them actually too that's very
impressive
but it's way more than that you can keep
an eye on every single
inch of your home which is especially
great for me when i'm on the road
because i know that sweet little elisa
and cute little june do not need to open
that door
before they can know who is outside of
that door
ring means that i can talk to whoever
shows up and i can say hey you hey in
law get out of here no i'm kidding i
would never say that to my in-laws
ring right now is a special offer for
you go to ring.com
knowles scanner wlas it's a perfect way
to start your ring experience
one of the best benefits you just
install it yourself it takes minutes
even
i can do it's very simple protect your
home anytime from anywhere with ring
alarm go to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today
build the system that's right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
ring.com
knowles that is ring.com slash knowles
the mainstream lame stream establishment
legacy i forget what we're supposed to
call them now
the old media the old corrupt leftist
media
cannot get enough of the texas democrats
who are currently breaking the law and
spreading kovit to everybody
our friends at the media research center
put together just
a little montage to give you a
smattering for those of us who don't
watch this sort of stuff on tv
of the coverage that the texas demons
are getting the texas democrats who
blocked a voter suppression bill and
fled to dc
are showing how to fight for voting
rights more than 50 elected democrats
left texas last night
to block the passage of new voter
suppression laws
more than 50 texas democrats flee the
state
all fighting for voting rights these
democratic lawmakers are trying to stop
a controversial voting law
using the only tool they have left in a
last-ditch effort to block a voting
restrictions bill
they are running away to block a
republican effort there to limit the
ways people can vote
texas republicans are trying to push
through new restrictions restrictive
voting rights bills one of the most
restrictive voting bills in the country
why is this bill even necessary texas
state democrats are trying to fight back
showing democrats here in the capitol
how to fight democrats are bracing for
their next battle against voter
suppression efforts you know when you
talk about what you're sacrificing you
are sacrificing a lot
why was it so important to you to make
this sacrifice what are democrats
prepared to do to protect our elections
what are you the voter prepared to do so
the corporate media the regime media are
pushing one message which is that this
is voter suppression and this is
terrible it's a threat to our democracy
now what the republicans in texas and
elsewhere are doing
is in many cases just bringing back the
election integrity measures that we had
18 months ago
bringing back and reaffirming election
integrity measures that we had
before corrupt politicians used covet as
an excuse to
take away all of our election integrity
measures including those that even
barack obama
some years ago said were very important
it shows you something we've been
talking about for many many days now and
weeks actually
the disparity between the people
and the ruling class that purports to
speak for the people
the vast majority of americans support
the voting rights measures that you're
seeing go into place in texas
this is clearly true as a matter of the
majority of texans because the majority
of texans
elected these representatives who are
now putting in place these voter
measures but it's true around the
country and it's true across
demographic groups that has widespread
support and yet the corporate media
which is the stooge of the liberal
ruling class
is pretending that the people are crying
out no
our democracy is crying out for election
integrity
the people are crying out to have their
votes protected
with election integrity measures not by
taking away election integrity measures
because when
people who are not eligible to vote vote
that steals a vote from eligible voters
that suppresses
that truly suppresses people's right to
vote so of course
i don't want to hear the liberal regime
lecture me
on the importance of masking they don't
believe in it they never have i don't
want them to lecture me on the thread of
covid they don't believe it they never
have
and most of all i don't want them to
lecture me
on threats to our democracy they hate
our democracy and as
angelo cotaville points out when they
talk about our democracy
what they're talking about is their
oligarchy and some people have had
enough rand paul rand paul if he never
does anything else in his
political career but just smack down
anthony fauci
it will have been a life well lived it
will have been a political career
that was worth it dr fauci the most
powerful politician in the country who's
never appeared on the ballot who no one
has ever voted for
who is accountable basically to no one
presidents come and go
dr fauci remains fauci has been caught
in lie
after lie after lie about the masks
and about how long it's going to go on
and about this that and the other thing
but most notably
he's been quite dishonest on the subject
of the virus's origins he dismissed
what all of us plainly saw early on
which was a connection between the wuhan
laboratory and the virus
he dismissed it he tamped it down he
contradicted it then when the evidence
was so obvious he
opened the door a little bit again and
he said okay possibly he denied
that his organization at the nih
was funding gain of function research
the kind of research
that beefed up the viruses such as kovid
he he denied that his department at the
nih was funding
this kind of stuff going on at the wuhan
laboratory
and he denied this under oath rand paul
believes he purged himself and i do too
now it's clear that that did happen and
he's fighting desperately tooth and nail
and rand paul won't let him get away
with it now you're getting into
something if the point
that you are making is that the the
grant
that was funded as a sub award from eco
health
to wuhan created sars kovi 2.
that's where you are getting let me
finish we don't know
wait a minute it didn't come in the lab
but all the evidence is pointing that it
came from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating
senator because if you look at the
viruses
that were used in the experiments that
were
given in the annual reports that were
published in the literature
it is molecularly impossible no one's
saying those viruses
those virus caused the pandemic what
we're alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab
and nih funded it that is get away from
it it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i am not
obfuscating the truth you are the one i
am
expired but i will allow the witness to
let me just finish no you
are no uh i am a rubber and you are glue
in this senator excuse me senator
whatever you
say will bounce off of me and stick to
you
okay senator and that actually is
probably true because the media
will will just cover for fouchy and will
dishonestly attack rand paul but what
rand paul is saying
is 100 true and you've got to pay
attention to what
a talented politician dr fauci is
fauci earlier on you remember we played
the clip on this show
when rand paul found out that dr fauci
was in fact funding gain of function
research and was in fact funding the
wuhan laboratory
dr fauci said that is not true
we were not funding that kind of
research and even if we were it's
totally fine
right he said hold on well what is it it
wasn't happening but
okay it was and it's cool i like it
actually can't have those things
simultaneously
so what rand paul says is
you denied funding all this kind of
stuff you denied that this kind of
research was going on
now we know that both things are true
and people are going to be held
responsible
for funding this laboratory where this
gain of function research was happening
then dr fauci comes out and he says the
specific
grants that we were making were not
specifically for viruses
such as soros covid such as the wuflu
but that's not what rand paul was saying
so then rand paul comes back to him and
fauci is trying to just stall here and
just kind of run out the clock
but rand paul's saying no no i'm not
saying that you funded this specific
virus
i'm saying that you funded gain of
function
research you funded this laboratory
where gain of function research was
happening
and you should not have been doing that
you don't need to be funding the
specific virus that they're working on
to know that it's a problem
to be funding a place in our at our
greatest geopolitical threat china
where they're doing this kind of
research that can shut down the global
economy
and dr fauci just keeps trying to just
change the topic just a little bit
so that he can grandstand he's a very
adept politician which is why he's
outlasted
so many presidents and you're going to
see the corporate media who none of us
elected
flacking for dr fouchu none of us
elected over rand paul who a lot of
people elected this is
this is so typical you are going to see
the blob
which for a hundred years now has become
less and less and less accountable
to the people and to our constitutional
system you're going to see them all
flack for one another
and we the people are going to be called
the threat to democracy
you saw it yesterday on twitter great
example
twitter hipster rasputin jack dorsey
whom none of us have elected
suspended a duly elected member of the
united states house
of representatives marjorie taylor green
she is the real boogeyman now the left
hates marjorie taylor green because she
said like kooky things on facebook some
years ago
so say see she's tear we got to kick her
out we got to give more power to the
blob
and less power to anyone who's ever said
anything kooky on facebook
so marjorie taylor green tweeted out
quote
the controversial covid19 vaccines
should not be forced on our military for
a virus that is not dangerous for
non-obese people and those under 65.
with 6 000 vax related deaths and many
concerning side effects reported
the vaccine should be a choice not a
mandate for everyone
what's the lie this this was taken down
for misleading information about covid19
what's the lie
okay i'll tell you i'll tell you what
their excuse was
to temporarily suspend her account and
to say that this was misleading
they said that the virus is not
dangerous for non-obese people in those
under
65 but what they'll they'll say well
a handful of people who are not obese
who are under 65
faced serious consequences so lie five
pinocchios ten thousand pinocchios
that's a lie
mostly false six thousand facts related
deaths they'll say there are six
thousand
reported deaths but we haven't confirmed
that those deaths are
they were reported to the vera's vaccine
injury system but we don't know we
haven't confirmed
so that ten thousand pinocchios that's a
lie many concerning side effects
reported i guess that part is just
obviously now admitted by the cdc and
the fda even though at first they tried
to deny it okay so that part they're not
gonna say
and therefore the vax should be a choice
not a mandate for everyone
well that's that's wrong they'll say
that's a lie too
they'll say even a normative statement
even a statement of what policy we
should have they could they'll say
that's a lie because
the experts in the media and in the
scientific public health establishment
whom no one elected
they are to make our public policy they
are to be our rulers
rather than our duly elected
representatives according to the
progressive world view
dr fauci and jack dorsey have a far
greater right to rule than someone whom
the people
elected now when you want to make sure
that you've got the right people in the
right positions i would strongly
recommend
ziprecruiter the most important
investment you can make as a business
owner is in your people
much more important than the desks and
the chairs and the computers and
anything else
time is money first of all when you're
trying to hire and also the wrong
personnel decision can cause so many
headaches down the road
now finding the right person to hire can
feel like a needle in a haystack
okay you post your job to some job board
and then you just hope that the right
person sees it
it comes along you got to try zip
recruiter zip recruiter right now you
can try for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles when you post a job on
ziprecruiter
it gets sent out to over 100 top job
sites with one click
then ziprecruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply zip
recruiters so effective that four out of
five employers who post on ziprecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day it's no wonder that over 2.3 million
businesses
have come to zip recruiter for their
hiring needs
we love zip recruiter here at daily wire
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options ziprecruiter finds
you
what you're looking for the needle in
the haystack right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at zipcruder.com
knowles zipcritter.comwles
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
you know what else you got to check out
you had to check out the morning wire
it's a great show it is a great show
it's brought to you by the daily wire
editor and chief john bickley
co-host georgia howe morningwire will
wake you up with the latest developments
in politics sports culture and education
all with a heavy emphasis on facts some
of our shows
take the facts and then bring in
analysis from philosophy and literature
and religion and history
that's what we try to do on this show
that's what ben does and drew and matt
this show it's giving you just the facts
in a very tight format right in the
morning to start your day
morning wire is already ranking at the
top of the apple charts it's available
now
so subscribe to morning wire on apple
podcast spotify everywhere you listen to
podcasts
so you don't miss a beat and if you like
what you hear leave a five-star review
help us
keep delivering the news that you need
to know also
right after you order speechless
controlling words controlling mine's my
book number one national bestseller
thank you those of you who
are reading it now after you do that you
should pre-order ben's book the
authoritarian moment which hits
bookshelves
next tuesday july 27th go to
dailywire.com
ben to order your signed copy today then
we'll be doing a live stream book
signing
next tuesday the 27th so pre-order your
signed copy now
when you do you'll be asked to type in a
question at checkout then catch
tuesday's live signing
to see if he's answered your question
watch him sign your book
get your copy of the authoritarian
moment my future campaign slogan
at dailywire.com ben we'll be right back
with a lot more
coronavirus is spiking in some places
around the country and it's not just on
democrat private jets though it is
spiking there
it actually is it's a i i hope none of
them face serious consequences from the
virus
looking at the statistics it's very
unlikely that they will face serious
consequences
and so because of that it's it's
probably pretty funny that the people
who have been
hammering this issue are also the ones
who are ignoring all the precautions
they want everyone else to take
and where the cases are spiking but you
know where else they're spiking
among illegal aliens new report from fox
news
says that the number of illegal aliens
testing positive for the coronavirus in
the rio grande valley
sector of texas has skyrocketed guess
what the increase is
compared to the previous 14 months just
guess
you think it's 9 no you think it's 90
percent
no it's 900 percent
900 and so you're going to hear your
benevolent bettors tell you
hey don't go on vacation hey just stay
stay home don't go out if you don't need
to in la you're getting another mask
mandate even if you've taken the vaccine
hey you've got everyone needs to get
vaccinated right away
super duper hey no you shouldn't really
go to school yet you shouldn't go to
church you shouldn't go to businesses
just ignore those people
just ignore them because they obviously
don't believe it
because if our ruling class really
believed that any of that were really
important to the public health
they would shut down the border you
can't say
that it's dangerous for vaccinated
americans who have been locked down for
18 months to leave their homes
but it's totally cool for unvaccinated
untested
illegal foreign nationals to pour across
our border
to the tune of almost 200 000 a month
you can't say that and be consistent
what this is about
it's not so much a virus not so much the
particular public health measures
it's about the imposition it's about who
rules us we mentioned it a little bit
yesterday about the rates of covid among
the illegal aliens well now this new
report 900 increase
and there's no end in sight to the
foreign nationals pouring into the
country
speaking of spikes bad news for the rest
of us here in america
because we knew this was going to happen
the title of the show yesterday was
the bill comes due there's a lot of
fears of inflation right now
well john katz metidis who's a very
well-known guy in new york if you're not
from new york maybe you haven't heard of
him
he ran for mayor or governor i think it
was mayor
some years ago he's the owner of
gristiti's very popular grocery chain
in new york and just a magnate in the
supermarket business
well john katzen metidis is predicting
that the price of your groceries
is going to spike and it's going to
spike more than it has already it's
going to spike
very soon you know we're both in the
food business and we're in the oil
business
and food prices are are getting higher
and we expect even more uh
increases by october uh and we're
we're seeing anywhere from 10 to 14
percent by october 1st
so it's a real number and oil prices
i know they're a little bit off today
but i expect even higher numbers
and it's a real uh it's it's a sine wave
and then everything just goes up and
down but it's
uh i expect by october uh you're gonna
have
uh over a six percent annualized rate of
inflation
so you're gonna have over a six percent
annualized rate of inflation
you're going to see ten to fourteen
percent according to cats metidius by
october first
it's a real number he says 10 to 14
percent
inflation on your groceries and then
even after that spike because he says
you know it's a sine wave it goes up and
down but even after that spike you're
gonna see six percent annualized
but at least your fourth of july cookout
was 16 cents
cheaper that's what joe biden said on
on the 4th of july yeah the cost of your
barbecue is 16 cents cheaper
cool at least you're not getting mean
tweets
right at least the mean orange man
is not doing doing what i don't know i
don't even colluding with the russians
and the ukrainians
whatever neither of which turned out to
be true and instead they
installed a guy who who did collude with
the ukrainians because the sun was being
bought off
by anyway you know we've talked about
the hunter biden story a lot
anyway what's the point in even
complaining about it that's the world
we're in right now
okay that's the regime that we are
living under
and it's not just joe biden joe biden
doesn't know what end is up
joe biden is a vessel of this
liberal establishment of the regime that
involves
big tech and higher education and lower
education
and the multinational corporations and
the news media and all of it
nicole hannah jones is the
person who created the 1619 project at
the new york times trying to reframe
american history reframe our country
away from what it once was
to now this increasingly radical
left-wing
regime nicole hannah jones
has some curious things to say about
cuba yes you know right now there's
uh protests going on in cuba i'm not
sure it quite amounts to a revolution
but
people are challenging the dominant
regime in cuba the communist
dictatorship
the regime says it will do anything to
maintain power and they're already
beating people and killing people in the
streets
nicole hannah jones believes that cuba
actually is an exemplar that cuba is
the most racially equitable country in
the
atmosphere she said this this is a while
ago in 2019
she's been pretty quiet about cuba the
last few weeks she says it's the most
equal
multi-racial country in our atmosphere
she said this in an interview with vox
uh it vox's ezra climb
and she said that socialism was the
factor behind cuba's
reported or purported equality
we're getting a little taste of that
right now i'm not saying we live under a
communist dictatorship we're not we're
not there we're living under something a
little bit different you might call it
managerialism
you might call it surveillance
capitalism is a new term that's going
around you're living under a kind of
corporatism it's not but it's not
not quite communism but but i think
you're getting to see a taste of this
equality does not imply a standard of
living
people can be equal when everyone's
really rich and doing very well
and people can be equal when everyone's
really poor and miserable
and people can be unequal but everyone's
doing very well
in terms of material wealth and people
can be unequal
and most people are poor and some some
few people are very very wealthy
and it's that latter category that
you're starting to see here masquerading
as equality people are not equal
in cuba the castro regime were
billionaires
and virtually everyone else was very
very poor
but okay you take a few people a few of
the lucky ones who are maintaining power
out of it and everyone's equal and
everyone's miserable
that i think is what what they're after
here and and it is what you're seeing by
the way you're seeing
uh beefing up of policies to support the
poorest of the poor
you're seeing the richest of the rich
get richer and richer and richer
including jeff bezos who i'm very
pleased with today so i'm not you know
i'm not even i'm not even just singling
him out i'm just pointing out
that the richest class they're doing
much much better
and what's being hollowed out is the
middle class
they're the ones seeing their jobs
shipped overseas they're the ones seeing
their opportunities curtailed
they're the ones seeing their
communities destroyed they're the ones
who are
seeing confiscatory sort of policies
pushed upon them
they're the ones who are seeing their
dollar devalued they're
they're you know disproportionately so
that that's the real play here and it's
a hollowing out of political power
because if you hollow out that american
middle class then you are transferring
not just wealth
but political power away
now speaking of regime change that might
be happening in cuba right now
i've got to get to this clip of general
petraeus general petraeus one of the
one of the top guys in the united states
military former director of the cia he
was ousted over a sex scandal
petraeus though was a head of u.s
central command
he's played a very important role in in
the wars in the middle east over the
last 20 years
general petraeus is criticizing what he
considers to be the
hasty decision to withdraw from
afghanistan
i fear that we will look back and regret
the decision to withdraw
and i think sadly we may regret that
sooner than i had originally thought
when i said that right after the
decision was announced beyond that i
think we'll also look back and and
regret the
the hasty way in which we seem to be
doing this
uh with no plan yet but what i see now
sadly
uh is uh the onset
of what is going to be quite a brutal
civil war
considerable ethnic and sectarian
displacement assassination of government
officials
millions of refugees flooding into other
countries particularly pakistan
uh we will see the return of al qaeda in
the islamic state though i don't
see a an immediate domestic security
uh threat for the u.s in that regard
okay the war that we've been fighting
for 20 years
we're now getting out of and this is a
hasty decision according to general
petraeus
i want to be careful here i'm not saying
that there's never an
argument to fight a war for 20 years
actually for much of our civilization's
history the united states doesn't really
like long wars
but the west has i mean the england the
mother country
fights wars by the decade and by the
century you have the hundred years war
and and uh
other other such engagements so i'm not
i'm not against
long wars-ness but necessarily
but what is the purpose of the war in
afghanistan i think we need to be honest
about that
the purpose of the war in afghanistan
the point the aim
is just to be there it's just an
occupation
it's just to sort of keep the relative
peace
and impose our interests there it's a
war of empire
fine like many of those british wars it
can be a war of empire
but then we have to acknowledge that the
united states is an empire and the
people who are
instituting that empire don't want to
acknowledge that they want to pretend
that it's something else and a lot of
americans in the uni
americans in the united states a lot of
a lot of our people
don't want an empire they want a nation
and i think
the debate right now is not so much
democrat versus republican or left
versus right
it's the people who want an american
nation
versus the people who want a liberal
empire and on the side of liberal empire
you have some people who are republican
or traditionally
more conservative like general petraeus
like
george w bush like a number of other
people
and you have people who are
traditionally on the left wing you've
got the corporate media
you've got various other pla the state
department largely
now who's trying to pull out of
afghanistan well joe biden is sort of
making the call here isn't he but donald
trump made the call before that
so it doesn't cut neatly along these
sorts of
partisan lines i think it's a much more
fundamental debate that donald trump's
election really threw into stark light
do we want to have a nation an american
nation
and if we do what kind of nation is that
going to be or do we want to have a
liberal empire is our flag the flag of
the
stars and strifes the flag of the
american nation or is it the rainbow
flag or the blm flag that makes these
sort of universal claims that we're now
flying at
at embassies around the world
speaking of regime change there is
regime change potentially going on in
california you know
bruce jenner is running to replace
gavin newsom that's probably very bad
for the republican party since
jenner himself has said that he doesn't
care about the republican party he
doesn't care about the trump agenda
he's just he's mostly loyal to the lgbt
lmnop crowd and specifically to
transgenderism so that's not good that's
he ain't my candidate there's some other
candidates who don't have very high name
id and aren't raising a lot of money and
then there's larry elder my friend larry
elder
has a national presence could maybe make
a play here
and larry elder has been kept off of the
ballot by the california
secretary of state here's why people are
wondering
why is my name not on the list of
candidates to
recall governor gavin newsom in this
recall election got this letter from the
secretary of state
democrat here are the following reasons
why you might be disqualified
no declaration of candidacy was filed
doesn't apply
nomination signature requirement was not
met doesn't apply
no income tax return disclosure consent
and acknowledgment form was filed
doesn't apply
no income tax return were filed doesn't
apply
the only box check listen to this
incomplete redacted or
unredacted income tax returns were filed
we filed both redacted and unredacted
tax returns
so i guess what they're saying is we
redacted something that shouldn't have
been redacted
or we didn't redact something that
should have been redacted
never has anybody been disqualified from
a ballot here in california for a reason
like that
this morning i'll see you in court out
love larry's response here this is a
bogus technicality
they passed this law that you need to
have do you submit your tax returns as a
way to
go after donald trump because they
wanted trump to release his tax returns
this was struck down for the
presidential but they kept that
provision in place
for lower races including gubernatorial
larry elder's saying
i met all of the requirements but i
think what they understand in california
is that larry elder is probably the
greatest threat to gavin newsom even if
he's not
a major threat he's still probably the
greatest threat out there so they're
trying to keep him off the ballot and he
will see them
in court
one of the great statesmen of our age is
not
a republican politician he's not a
democrat politician he's not a dictator
he's not an oligarch he is
tom brady tom brady was at the white
house this week
and he demonstrated such political skill
at some point this guy's going to have
to run for office he's so
obviously very good-looking very popular
very wealthy
he checks every box for a politician
but he also strikes the right note
so tom brady standing right next to
president biden
made some pretty wild political jokes
and no one can quite tell where where
they landed
but we found our rhythm we got on a roll
not a lot of people
uh you know think that we could have won
and um in fact i think about 40 percent
of the people still don't think we won
i understand you understand that mr
president
and personally you know it's nice for me
to be back here
we had a game in chicago where i forgot
what down it was
i lost track of one down and 21 years of
playing
and they started calling me sleepy tom
sleepy tom okay now obviously someone
either at the white house
or on tom brady's team wrote the jokes
maybe both
but the jokes are really good political
jokes
and they're really good political jokes
especially for this moment where tom
brady
who is very famously friends with donald
trump
is he's not boycotting the white house
like all those immature athletes who
didn't like trump
but he's showing up there and he's
making some jokes about biden
but the jokes could be seen to biden's
benefits so the first one is yeah people
didn't think we could win about 40
of people still don't think we could win
yeah you know what that's like mr
president
because biden can go along with the joke
because
brady did win so he's saying yeah those
40 of people are wrong
but also he's getting the making the
point from the white house that 40
of americans don't believe joe biden won
that election that's a pretty
pretty indicting number then you see him
make the
sleepy tom joke yeah you know i forgot
this and
they called me sleepy tom well he's
the part of the joke that biden can go
along with is that you know look this
just happened once and people are
making a big deal about this but the
part of the joke that's actually
pro-trump and anti-biden
is he's saying yeah i mean i forgot
something and so people are comparing me
to you
mr president who you can't remember
anything because you're a daughtering
old man it's just
ver i'm not i'm not saying like yeah tom
you totally roasted biden and i'm not
saying tom you jerk you sold out trump
i just want to point out the political
skill of of staying
right on that line walking that
tightrope very
very impressive stuff for uh if and when
tom brady wants to get involved in
politics
it was rather charming too it's kind of
a gentleman you know i mean when you
think of
all these athletes today who are just
making these childish ugly
statements colin kaepernick the hammer
girl from the olympics you just think
ugh
gross tom brady shows up there and he
just has a little bit of charm and he
tells some jokes and he jokes
you can laugh at them if you're on the
right you can laugh at them if you're on
the left
i think we need more of that in politics
speaking of disbelief
the white house communications director
kate bettingfield
has now gone on television to double
down
on the white house's position that
social media companies need to do their
bidding and censor their political
opponents
when facebook and twitter and other
social media outlets spread false
information
that cause americans harm shouldn't they
be
held accountable in a real way shouldn't
they be
liable for publishing that information
and then open to lawsuits
well we're reviewing that and certainly
they should be held accountable and i
think you've heard the president speak
very aggressively about this he
understands this is an important piece
of the ecosystem but it's also the other
thing the president has pointed out and
spoke to
when he was asked about this yesterday
is it's it is also the responsibility of
the people creating the content and
again i would go back to
you know there are conservative news
outlets who are creating
irresponsible content that's sharing
misinformation about the
about the virus that's getting shared on
these platforms so it is a big and
complicated ecosystem
and everybody bears responsibility to
ensure that we are not
providing people with bad information
about a vaccine that will save their
lives
i hope trump's lawyers are taking good
notes here
donald trump is suing these social media
companies for allegedly violating his
first amendment rights
it's a very hard lawsuit to argue
because you have to argue
that the government is using social
media to enforce its own policies right
remember the first amendment
is only puts certain obligations on
the government so if a private entity
violates
your free speech rights that's generally
speaking not going to fall under the
first amendment
but if the government is using big tech
as a proxy
if they are colluding with big tech if
they're threatening big tech
to to get big tech then to clamp down on
political opponents
then that that would fall under the
first amendment it's as though the biden
white house
wants to walk right into this and maybe
they've got some really clever 4d
strategy
for dhs or maybe they just think there's
no way that the conservatives are going
to get them that
the liberal regime has so much power
that no judge is going to really rule
against them and the media are going to
flack for them and it's just
they're not going to face any
consequences
but we will really really troubling
story coming out of
arizona state university an asu
professor
uh right now arguing that parents
should lose quote veto power over
transiting their kids so you know right
now the culture
and a lot of the public health
professionals and a lot of the
institutions are
encouraging children to mutilate
themselves and
encouraging little boys to pretend that
they're little girls and they're saying
this is being taught in preschools
public preschools in new york this is
being taught all over the place
parents thankfully can still go in and
say hey don't
lop off my kids genitals hey don't pump
my kids full of cross-sex hormones
well one one professor maura priest
is arguing in the journal of medical
ethics
that parents should not have that right
she says quote puberty suppression is
consistent with the proper goals of
medicine to promote well-being and
therefore could ethically be offered
to non-binary adults in principle it is
proper to medicine now of course
mutilation is not proper to medical
goals because mutilation takes
otherwise healthy organs and harms them
and that's what happens when you
pump a little kid full of cross-sex
hormones and pretend that little johnny
is little jane
but this shows you the end of things so
this the squishy position of hey let
anyone do whatever they want you know
okay i
maybe don't do it to kids but let adults
make whatever choices they want
this doesn't work because you're you're
eventually you have to make some claims
of the good if
if a man really can become a woman and
it is really good for men who think that
they're women to
to be mutilated to look like they're
women then obviously that treatment
if it's if it is a medical treatment
then obviously that needs to be offered
to kids
and at a certain point we've got to
ditch this silly language of choice
choice choice
and get down to what is good and what is
true and what is beautiful
we'll need to look up for that i think
we'll need some inspiration we can look
up to where jeff bezos's space
pod is and maybe look up a little
further
to the objective moral order and the god
that created that order i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles shall see
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show